ah Ron the country where the far-right
wing as it is known today was born way
before the financial crisis way before
Donald Trump the game the President of
the United States way before brexit and
the uprising of xenophobic parties in
Europe way before all of that France had
an extreme Nationalist Party the
National Front and it had a real chance
to win an election actually in 2002 the
rest of the political players in the
country from the center left to the
center-right had to join forces just to
keep a strong marine lepen
from becoming the president of France in
April 2017 French people are going back
to the voting stations and a lot of
people think that this is the ultimate
chance for the far-right wing
in France the moment where the National
Front with marine lepen has its leader
and get the presidential office once and
for all if this was the case marine
lepen who by the way is the daughter of
jean-marie Le Pen has promised that she
will do everything she can to take a
country out of the European Union but
not only that Frances the second largest
country in continental Europe a victory
for the extreme right would be a triumph
for all far-right parties on the
continent
[Music]
you
but do just wait one minute because the
question is really does marine lepen
have a real chance of winning this
election is there anyone out there who
can possibly suffer today we are going
to answer all of these questions and
we're going to get to know in depth the
history of the French extreme right a
story that includes Wars ego clashes and
well playmates so let's get into it
lepen clan the French extreme right has
two ideological grandparents Adolf
Hitler and the OAS and you know during
World War Two the Germans invaded the
north of front
[Music]
the South the so-called free zone whose
capital with Vichy was governed by
French politicians who supported the
German national socialism when war ended
the new president General Charles de
Gaulle executed the main official from
Vichy but do wait one minute again
because there were many people who
supported this collaborationist
government people that even without
having too little power held the same
principles and the same ideals as the
National Socialists from Nazi Germany
[Music]
and many of them were in the army
decades later in 1961 the French lets
their most precious colony Algeria hold
a self-determination referendum as you
can imagine this was not great news for
all of those far-right extremists inside
the French army this is how the OAS was
born the OAS was a terrorist group whose
main goal with the end of the Algerian
attempt to the independence we are not
terrorists to understand we are patriots
our duty is to the soldiers who died
fighting in Algeria and with the three
million French citizens why what was it
there so did they succeed well actually
no in 1962 Algeria became a sovereign
state and then the OAS changed their
goals and trying to kill the French
president himself they thought that the
goal was a traitor to France fortunately
though in 1965 the French police
dismantled the last cells of this group
just like what happens after the end of
world war things out of jailing the
hardliners
didn't mean there were no people
supporting the generals course
from the country's liberty equality and
fraternity has a large amount of people
who hated the Algerians and having them
soldiers of the Third Reich and this was
the foundation that jean-marie the pen
used to build ten years later the
National Front solution to the media
when we talk about the war over and over
every day we are reminded of what would
war the persecution of the Jews
the excessive behavior of the occupying
forces and so on the beginning of this
party with no easy thing during the
nineteen seventies the National Front
would never get more than five percent
of the vote and the real upend himself
suffered a terrorist attack in his own
house
now this though is when the really good
parts are in 1977 that Philip M family
inherited from a fellow supporter an
entire palace
[Music]
this was the mantra to Palace soon this
would become the unofficial headquarters
for the National Front or as we probably
could just say villa pen family yes my
friends with this party everything does
stay in the family
Gonzalez jean-marie organized all those
electoral campaigns that made him the
third biggest political force in France
at the end of the nineteen eighty-three
was his daughter marine lepen was
following him and learning the secret of
the art of politics in order to become
the leader that she is today
later his granddaughter Mary all of em
would follow him to and she is now an MP
in the French parliament and a rising
star in the National Front interestingly
though even though his party
congratulate him as the champion of
Family Values the tennis family is far
from a happy one
yes yes I do know here visual politic we
really don't like to gossip about anyone
but in this case it's kind of absolutely
necessary do you understand me political
[Music]
like that in the 1980s Oh Marie Levin
who we will now call the pen fumiya was
on fire in every election he was getting
more and more votes than the previous
one it was during this time that he
decided to hire a journalist Katoon
write his own biography and of course he
led the journalists palace
so can you guess what this journalist
did well you probably can't unless you
already know he seduced lepen wife oh
but it's not just that these two lovers
then ran away from the palace and months
later misses with them with on the cover
of French Playboy magazine and this is
how the whole world discovered the more
sensual side of the extreme right now
this course a split in the family no
matter how good the father was doing in
the elections his daughter still grew
more and more distant from him but the
real turning point in the lepen family
would come in the year 2002 this was a
year when France had presidential
elections and for the first time in
history full of em went to the second
round
now as you might know the French
electoral system has to round when they
are choosing president in the first
rounds they can choose from all of the
candidates however many that may be and
in the second round you can only vote
for the two most successful candidates
in the first round welcomed in 2002 the
ones who needed into the second round
were shocked Chirac from the center
right-wing party and lapentti Nia from
being extreme right
[Music]
[Applause]
and so now you might be wondering how
did it happen that there was two
right-wing candidates so means are the
notables in France well during these
years lepen learned an important lesson
in politics the idea of the captive
voter as though that is going to find
some principles of the party attractive
no matter where they stand on the
political spectrum but then stood for
protectionism French companies but also
for French workers remember the America
first thing that ron was going on about
yeah well it turns out that's not
Trump's invention we defined the pen in
the 1990 so in 2002 industrial cities
like Marseille who used to be left-wing
strongholds voted for the National Front
[Music]
and this is why in that second round
those who remained loyal to the Social
Democratic Party had to swallow their
pride and food so shag share act to the
center right Candice I mean anything was
better than the uprising of a racist
extreme conservatives like lahpet
[Music]
and digits elder lepen family learned a
second important lesson in politics it
is not only important to be accepted by
your own voters you also can't be too
scary to the other people if your
opposition are too frightened they might
join forces to prevent you from getting
into that presidential palace Rheem vs.
jean-marie versus Merry Christmas was
another great time for the family after
2002 marine lepen started our internal
campaign against her father now don't
forget that jean-marie Le Pen was a
politician that ran for elections with
statements like this one there has to be
an authority always and we believe that
in a household the best one to have
disabilities is the man nonetheless
marine lepen was a woman ready to have
authority and modernize a political
party that would honestly make Windows
95 look like a piece of state-of-the-art
software now unlike asada marine
supported gay civil unions and was
against the death penalty even National
Front voters could appreciate these
changes and this is why in 2011 lepen
jr. took her father's place as the
party's leader our that do you know
things are things with a DP the equities
you've posted okay I wonder what
motivated marine and her deputies in
this offensive they have been launched
against me issues of July just think
about it when you've been the founder
and the leader of a French far-right
political party for 39 years it's not
going to be easy taking orders from your
daughter so even though today jean-marie
Le Pen is the honorary president of the
National Front he also votes as an
independent at the European Parliament
he'd say my campaigns not from marine
lepen
but for jean-marie Le Pen and I won 33%
and yet he's his main supporter inside
of the family surprise surprise family
business again it's his granddaughter
Mary on lepen who is starting her own
battle against her haunts Marie
politician right is a provocateur and
anti conformist and it isn't always nice
to hear meanwhile Marines moderation in
combination with the end of the crisis
in France are working way better than
the radical strategies of our Father
cannot grasp ok consider okay little pal
committee I considered Europe has made a
mistake in the past they should have
started cooperation and development
relationships of Africa this way they
would have fixed the people in their own
countries in fact the latest horses for
this 2017 election gives her close to 25
percent of the vote this makes every
first or second biggest candidate and in
an election with five candidates 25% is
a big thing it is always certain that
she will make it into the second round
but do you consider that just because
she is less radical than her father this
doesn't mean the Perrine is a moderate
in fact far from it
fameless' 144 points of her electoral
manifesto lepen Junius stands for
closing frontiers of massive
deportations the exit of the European
Union and we return as the French
currency in total Castle combat document
all the same economic views as Vladimir
Putin this is true but this is nothing
new
either alright so you know if you're
probably know wondering well can lepen
actually become the next president of
France so let's address this question
with another question can start ahead
for years the center right wing in front
saw how the pen could feel their votes
yes it is true that a big share of the
National Front votes come from the left
wing but in a time of crisis family
values and anti-immigrant sentiments are
particularly attractive to conservative
voters so in 2016 the big party of the
center rice the Republicans chose a
candidate you also put forward some of
these proposals that made lepen famous
this man was Francois Fiat
[Music]
so in the strategy of working well well
apparently not
since senior became the party's
candidate the Republicans have been
falling on the polls and they are now
fighting for third position with far
right-wing party of jean-luc mélenchon
corruption sex scandals and the fact
that people prefer the original to the
copy this is course pinyon and the
center-right to fall into a Libyan but
there is still hope the battle is not
over there is still a man who could be
ready to stop the Pens Huracan his name
is Emmanuel macron and he was the
finance minister during the government
of Manuel Valls alright so in the manual
macron a socialist elmo macron is
running in the elections as an
independent
even Manuel Valls himself didn't
supported in public until relatively
recently so what does Emmanuel macron
stand for basically he stands to the
opposite of La Paz
[Music]
[Applause]
McCarron wants to end the privileges and
subsidies that French companies get he
wants to end the barriers that made it
impossible for the French youth to get a
job and the course years against
discrimination based on race or religion
when it comes to the economy wants to be
a champion for deficit reduction has
fiscal responsibility and as if that was
not enough one of his proposals is to
forbid high-ranking officials to employ
their own family in Salida the
administration so as you can see here's
the antithesis of marine lepen and
surprise surprise the latest polls
actually indicate that he is slightly
more popular than will mean the pent
with over 25 percent would be expected
both and all of this despite being an
independent so here's a high chance of
being the person that the pen will face
in the second round
[Music]
or maybe not because there is a last
variable that we must consider and that
abstention
even if micron has a lot of supporters
but they are simply not as motivated as
those from the left-hand side so for
example if during the second round the
National Front could retain 90 percent
of their votes and macron could only
retain 40 or 50 percent he would have
some great difficulty winning the
presidency
but I mean this is just our opinion of
visual politic and we would love to hear
yours do you think the chrome can beat
the pen in front are there any other
candidates that could make a surprise
resurgence during the election please do
leave us a comment below this video and
don't forget that we publish brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday
so do not forget to subscribe so you
don't miss any of those and if you did
like this video please do give it a
thumbs up below and as always I'll see
you next time
and don't forget to check out reconsider
a podcast about politics where we don't
do the thinking for you you can find us
at reconsider mediacom see you there
[Music]